state health leaders now make it easier  to save a digital copy of your  vaccination card a new platform has been  set up basically to create a record that  only verified health apps used by  medical staff can access more  information on how to do this is posted  to our website and the at home coveted  tests promised by governor sisolak have  started arriving in nevada a small  delivery being made to a site in ely  today more will be arriving through next  week so far none are here in the valley  these are different from the ones you  can order through the government but  will also be free you'll be able to pick  them up at places like clinics and  community centers